I think there's where the problem lies
there's this idea in your house that
you're in charge of the finances and I
think that's the mindset that led you to
think I read The Total Money Makeover I
got a great idea I'm going to go into
our savings and I'm going to pay the
bills and that's what's gotten you here
and I think that starting instantly
right now you're doing a vocab rehab and
from now on the both of you are managing
the money it's our responsibility to
manage our money
can we agree on
that yes been showing her like more like
statements and numbers and what our
investments are for through my employer
like my 401k and everything good and
I've realized that she was not even
aware of that and he broke me like it's
like no we're we're a team like there's
no it's not my money it's our money it's
our resources we take trips together we
we invest together we grow together like
we're a family